- [Narrator] King Charles III
is the UK's new head of state
and head of the royal family.
He's basically the CEO
of the British monarchy,
and he has said that
one of his priorities is
to bring down running costs.
Last year, the monarchy
cost the government
roughly 102 million pounds,
the equivalent of $117 million
according to the palace's
annual financial report.
So, here's what we know
about where that money comes
from and how it's spent.
- I take this opportunity
to continue the tradition
of surrendering the hereditary revenues,
including the crown
estate to my government
for the benefit of all.
- [Narrator] The cost of carrying
out official duties comes
from something called the sovereign grant.
Here's how that works.
In the 1700s, the monarchy handed
over revenues from swathes of land
known as the crown
estate to the government.
These days, the crown estate makes money
on a range of assets from retail property
to golf courses and even
offshore wind farms.
And every year the
government pays a percentage
of the profits made on those
assets back to the monarchy.
Last year, it totaled $99.6 million.
In addition to their vast private wealth
and income from investments,
which are not included here,
the monarchy also received $11.4 million
from royal palace admissions
and rental properties.
This slice of income is used
to supplement the grant.
But last year, the monarchy
also tapped a reserve
of grant money from past years
to meet its spending needs.
So, where did that money go?
The bulk of this spending goes
on the monarch's operating
costs, official travel,
and property maintenance.
In total, more than $3
million was spent last year
on helicopter trips and
journeys on the royal train.
And 10 times more than that was used
to employ about 1,000 people,
from footmen to florists,
who make up the royal household,
headquartered at Buckingham Palace.
The palace itself has high running costs,
and money spent on renovating it rose 41%
from the previous year.
A 10-year project to refurbish
Buckingham Palace is forecast
to cost around $426 million
according to the last financial report.
And there are costs we don't know.
Some royal watchers say the
bill is higher than stated
because of the costs of police
protection for the family,
and the cost of the
queen's funeral couldn't
immediately be determined.
- [Protesters] Freeze profits, not people.
- [Narrator] How this money is spent is
particularly pertinent at a time
when people are voicing concerns
about soaring energy bills,
and inflation in the UK is
at its highest in 40 years.
- Her Majesty's government's priority is
to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost
of living for families.
- [Narrator] $117 million
of taxpayer money works out
at about $1.73 or £1.50 per UK citizen.
King Charles seemingly wants
it to be even less than that.
Demonstrating that the monarchy is
good value for money is more difficult
in tougher economic times,
and Charles' plans are
part of a careful balancing act
deftly performed by his
mother for 70 years.
Now, it's his turn to
walk that tight rope.
(pensive string music)